the rare time I get to wear this
daredevil beanie in a video that's
related to daredevil it's my day it's my
time that's going reject nation and
how's it going Warren who's Warren you
might ask Warren is the man behind the
cosmic Wonder I did a collab with Warren
on Supes channel for an Avengers end
game spoiler talk quite a while ago ever
since then we communicate every couple
months about doing a collab even
recently we talked about it and it's
usually my fault we don't get around to
it consider this the first step to us
officially collabing Warren we're gonna
talk about this thing that I've been
seeing going around all over Twitter
apparently Charlie Cox possibly
returning as daredevil in spider-man 3
so I ran through plotly Charlie Cox
dinner overturning that's the title of
the video go check out the cosmic Wonder
YouTube channel he is a fantastic
youtuber hence why I've delayed it so
much because my ego is so big that I
don't wanted to get crushed by knowing
how much of a better youtuber war and
truly is
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about Marvel and of course the Marvel
Cinematic Universe today we are going to
be talking about spider-man 3 not only
do we have news about daredevil
returning but we have news that Charlie
Cox may be reprising his role and
beheaded hope it's true rumors have a
supposed plot leaked that talks about
how eight villains could possibly be in
spider-man 3 and not to mention
according to this leak the title could
possibly be at Anfield there's a lot
happening with a lot of movies right now
due to the corona virus but luckily for
us Brits hasn't gone in production yet
it's still in pre-production so as of
right now nothing has really been put on
hold with spider-man 3 but we know that
Tom Holland has met with Sony and Marvel
multiple times by now and as always we
know there are things to be discussed
things start to get leaked so we'll talk
about all the news and rumors that have
been out there in this video awesome if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up-to-date on spider-man 3 and all
things related to the MCU and stick
around to the end to hear about my
giveaway grayza what Ward today Kevin
Smith who many of you may know from
clerks and Jay and Silent Bob strike
back on his past fad manned beyond
podcast he mentioned Charlie Cox could
be returning to play the lawyer for
spider-man in spider-man 3 now I've
talked about daredevil returning several
times in several different videos and I
know that everybody wants Charlie Cox to
reprise the role as daredevil and now
that Kevin Feige is officially the CEO o
over Marvel in its entirety that means
he has creative control over all of the
TV shows that are coming on Disney plus
or elsewhere which means he has control
over whether the old Netflix characters
could enter at Disney Plus shows newer
to the MCU or a film do it by ganado MCU
for today Kevin Smith on his podcast
drop some news about Matt Murdock
possibly been in spider-man 3 he said I
heard another piece of good news
did you hear that spider-man the new
spider-man movie gonna have a lawyer in
it Charlie Cox
they're bringing in as Matt Murdock
there's been the rumor online and they
say that's like the one that like Marvel
like how did that get out now it's
important to note that Kevin Smith does
say that this is a rumor that he's heard
but you have to keep in mind that a
rumor for
him is very different than a rumor for
us he is in the film industry he's an
actor and he's a producer so the rumors
were years and from the poor Cooper's
them from have a lot more validity than
the ones that we hear so given his
connections he could have heard this
from a studio head and executive
producer or anyone else that could be
somehow associated with the new film a
lot of fans were really bummed out when
they cancelled the Netflix Marvel shows
and have been wanting them to come back
and in an interview Kevin Feige was
asked if these characters ever would
return and he did not rule it out and he
said that it was possible well we know
that spider-man is going to be on the
run after spider-man far from home
Mysterio revealed his identity and
framed it as a murder and we know that
based off of some things that Kevin
Feige said about Peter finally being on
his own and coming to his own as
spider-man he's not going to have the
typical help that he normally has and
spider-man homecoming he had Iron Man of
course and then in spider-man far from
home he had happy and Nick Fury kind of
Nick Fury but who's going to be there to
help him in spider-man 3 well it could
be Matt Murdock he should fight off the
people that are chasing him and he's
also going to need a lawyer to help him
not be wanted for murder anymore someone
who could help him person to be supposed
very early really draft of a script that
was leaked we introduced daredevil or
spider-man 3 in the supposing they
talked about daredevil appearing and
they talked about him being the one to
help out Peter Parker now some people
think that perhaps Jennifer Walters aka
she-hulk is going to be the person to
help out Peter Parker in spider-man 3
however we haven't heard anything about
this possibly happening we're not as
excited by this from Kevin 554 your
buddy at studios and we haven't even
heard any rumors about it so this isn't
really happen and if you think about
more along the lines of what Peter
Parker would need during this time when
he's on the run he would need more of a
stealthy ally because he's going to be
sneaking around so if you have a Hulk
that's just going to be big and smashing
everything that doesn't really work out
but let's talk about this recent plot
leaked that says that spider-man 3 could
have over eight villains in the movie I
don't know take this with a grain of
salt this was posted on Reddit yesterday
but then it was removed now sometimes
they
get posted on reddit or other social
media sites the studio sees them and
takes them down that usually means
they're on to something not necessarily
they're entirely accurate but some parts
of the leaks are accurate for example
there were some Wonder Woman 1984 photos
that were leaked online and Warner
Brothers actually took down all of the
photos from all different websites
including Twitter Instagram reddit
wherever so there could be some validity
to this leak so let's start it off by
talking about what this leak claims the
title could be for spider-man 3 and that
is Spider Man home run now this is kind
of a plan words obviously the first
thing you think is baseball but he is
running from home on the run so this
would make sense and it's kind of a
playful title because from everything
that we've heard about the night running
away come on Rob pretty dark
after all spider-man is wanted for
murder and according to the Morbius
trailer what we saw people don't really
like him too much to the point to where
they're spray-painting murderer over a
picture of him in the trailer also at
this point I should say spoiler alert in
case any of this ends up being true and
you were trying to avoid all spoilers
for spider-man 3 this league says that
the films going to have eight villains
Kraven is the main villain he hunts
spider-man for the prize just like in
the comics yes Sony is still planning a
Kraven solo film an aside antagonists
include scorpion vulture shocker
tinkerer Mysterio Prowler and silver
sable known Kraven is independent of the
sinister six and doing his own thing
scorpion is aligned with Peter after
finding out that he is innocent but that
comes later the film is a cat-and-mouse
extravaganza set a week after far from
home Peter is a man on the run with a
whole city out for his blood his
abilities and waitresses and skills are
put to the ultimate test okay The
Avengers co-star of the film is going to
be war machine with Don Cheadle
reprising his shadow when he feels
obligated to help Peter because of how
much Tony cared for him other returning
characters of the film including MJ on
May Peter Spears and JJJ Sony will be
casting Jessica drew soon and there's a
possibility that she could appear in a
post or mid-credits scene so a few
things to take note about this
supposedly k-- one is that it is
Vegh it is specific about some details
but still vague about others
now the sinister six showing up that
makes perfect sense they have been set
up in the MCU but one thing you'll
notice about this leak is that it
doesn't mention venom and it doesn't
mention Morbius will be delivered we
know that this is an MCU film and we
have yet to see anybody from Sony
spider-verse jump into the MCU yes we
have seen characters like vulture jump
over to Sony spider-verse
but never vice-versa and in fact Kevin
Feige said that Peter Parker spider-man
he specifically is the one with the
power to jump between universes not
anybody else so the fact that it doesn't
mention gonna more Morbius doesn't come
as that Oh amen also not to mention that
executive producer Ian Pascal watch that
in an interview not too long ago that if
you look at all of the characters that
have been introduced and spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
they have everyone that they need to
introduce the sinister six and that was
straight from the mouth of executive
producer for both spider-man films and
at that time we didn't have Morbius open
and does not exist in the MCU so if we
take all of the characters that we have
seen so far that's who this leaked says
is the sinister six and it lines up now
we know that Sony does have trouble or a
Kraven that I'm also worried confusion
lately because it has been thought that
Kraven is going to be the perfect
villain for spider-man 3 Peter Parker's
on the run and Kraven is the hunter what
better villain could there be when
spider-man is on the run and then of
course at the same time you have a
defeated Mysterio a lot of people do not
believe that Mysterio really died at the
end of far from home he is the master of
illusion and would it be that hard for
him to convince spider-man that he
really died but of course spider-man
defeated him so he could join another
group who was looking for revenge and
Sony also had plans on developing silver
sable as well and perhaps if they
introduced her and have her become good
by the end she could get her own
spin-off either in a movie or a TV show
but if we take in the supposted plot
leak and we add all of these different
villages know that spider-man's going to
hell because there's no way he can take
on eight different villains at the same
time after all he still is just a kid in
high school now it does say that he's
going to have help from Rhodey aka war
machine but how much can war machine
really be involved with a murderer and
that's where that murder
could possibly come in maybe rody
introduces Peter Parker to Matt Murdock
because he's a really good lawyer and he
also knows about him being daredevil he
really is the perfect character to be
spider-man's
ally in this film where he's on the run
not only could he help them to figure
out and of course Charlie Cox to return
as Matt Murdock in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and perhaps that is something
that we could possibly be getting
according to so what do you think about
this news that Charlie Cox could be
returning as daredevil and what do you
think about this plot leak that states
that there are going to be eight
villains and the third spider-man would
you like to see this better to let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date and all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers don't forget to
follow me on Twitter for live updates
and as old you give it as much for
watching like just will you have one way
well yeah I mean they're just about to
announce PS 5 so you gotta get rid of it
fast
oh damn or we got a collapse right when
you hit 500 50k yeah I want to win your
console system something alright guys
subscribe click that notification bell
see you guys soon great job Warren
thanks for doing the video last I heard
about this rumor a while ago Matt
Murdock possibly returning the fact that
it's been more in the zeitgeist as of
late that's the best word the zeitgeist
yeah when I learned that word I was like
that's a people meant for years oh yeah
the cultural zeitgeist is like just
onomatopoeia it's like one of those
words for your life oh yeah it's just so
cool to look at and then you learn it
you're like oh that's wouldn't you say
it and you just sound smart yeah like
when you say gravitas this is a great
intelligence word
let's move on yes from daredevil
vocabulary you know this would work
really well for a variety of reasons one
is a way you can reintroduce Matt
Murdock back into the MCU and put him
into the film's now I've never really
been a big
fan of the idea of daredevil being in
there at least not as a primary
supporting character but I've been a big
fan of Matt Murdock the lawyer being in
there to help out spider-man the way how
he like
defended Punisher in the comics and in
season two I thought it would be really
cool if they did that here that way it's
like a fun thing for the audience like
they really know he's daredevil we know
he's dead oh yeah I feel like having
daredevil in there you'd show up for the
third spider-man movie really wanting to
see a lot of daredevil taking place he
could kind of overshadow him and
spider-man's own movie basically but
what you were talking about here by the
time you got the last part of your video
that actually made me go well there's
actually a side of here that I can see
it potentially working now especially if
he is taking on so many villains my
problem though is that that's so many
villains yeah well there seems to be
some unwritten rule that spider-man
threes just need to have way too many
villains or something I really feel like
really amount of attention that
spider-man 3 still gets it shocks me
every time they're like let's jam pack
this next spider-man I mean yeah man
amazing spider-man 2 they they had too
many villains and there as well we all
just know that too many villains is a
problem oh hey and when you do that you
can't develop all those characters I
mean I've always thought that best movie
installment to do a sinister six in a
spider-man franchise parts Laprade yeah
parts I'm seriously part six right yeah
and there was that talk awhile ago
before Sony and Marvel had their fallout
deal that was a temporary of having like
nine spider-man movies so I was like
okay that'd be great if you put your
sister six in the sixth installment then
and now that the deal has been reworked
and they've only have him currently
slated for another crossover film and
then just a spider-man 3 to close it out
I could see a version of this where
Sony's like well this is last MCU movie
even if it's just like potentially this
might be his last movie we should
introduce all these villains to get
people excited to want to see them I'll
take place and our own Sony exclusive
spider-verse go out with a bang right
yeah cuz I could see that producer
mindset coming up in their board rooms
I'm right there with you on the 50/50
I'm like yeah I would love to see Matt
Murdock you know I've been hoping that
spider-man would become a legal drama oh
you know get some runaway jury in there
that's the tricky part is there's this
deal that has these limitations we don't
know how it's gonna progress from there
and so for an ideal situation yeah I
would love to see mostly Matt Murdock
maybe a glimpse of daredevil II but yeah
mostly get that relationship between him
and spider-man to leave the super stuff
to Peter yeah and then maybe in a future
installment we can have it to look
forward to or maybe they fight a little
bit together because you know that has
happened in the comics for sure but I
feel like that would be a nice thing to
build up to I feel like so many of these
things from the comics that people want
to see are nice to build up to rather
than just like plopping down inside of
stuff and I feel like that was a big
issue with the amazing spider-man series
as they tried to just plop the sinister
six down way too fast true I also that
rumor about possibly the Avenger
crossing over to help out from be an
Iron Man and the Nick Fury and happy
Hogan having Rhodey show up and the
reasoning that they were saying for why
Rhodey would want to help out with Peter
Parker I actually think is a strong
motive to be there for that character
sometimes a weird way to have these
characters shine more is put them in a
crossover as a main supporting type of
character show a different side dynamic
to them and I think that could really
give Rhodey specifically Don Cheadle's
Rhodey yeah a chance to shine because
after all the movies he's been in I'm
still in the cabin I know not everyone
is but I'm personally still in the camp
there's something about that portrayal
that I don't feel like has gone in his
due and Don Cheadle is an amazing actor
or however warns at it John shadow
doesn't she did I think I'd be a great
way to let Rhodey shine in there I don't
feel like he would steal the spotlight
away and there's not been a lot of
interaction between Warmachine and
spider-man there so I feel like he could
have a really fun game going beyond
being them all do the measures he's
heavily involved in the military so I'm
sure there's some connects he could pull
it whatever that I like Matt Murdock's
showing up I'm sure me saying like I
don't really want daredevil to be a
prevalent presence in here just keep
member Laura I'm sure in the movie if
they did have daredevil Joe I wouldn't
be complaining yeah oh yeah this is
awesome it's just which costume do I
want
yeah
yeah yeah there are some criticism that
a stem from the idea of like keeping the
Netflix characters alive in the movies
is one reason with the Russo brothers I
avoids but I heard was not including the
necklace characters like infinity war
and game was the fact to people who
watch the movies a lot of people don't
watch the Netflix show so you'd have to
reintroduce them so when I say
reintroduce into the movies that's
specifically what I'm referring to like
they'd be a great jumping-off point for
this character and as to the she-hulk
theory I don't even think that having
Matt Murdock necessarily preclude that
from happening
like occludes dude smart right word
thanks man really fool ooh really it
could even work to just introduce her in
her human form and then you know set
that up for later too you know
and then yeah you can have your spin-off
into Disney Plus or or whatever I think
there's a lot of interesting stuff here
and yeah the only the only really
troublesome thing is that sinister six
this sinister six especially for this
movie they already got such a great plot
set up for you spider-man's on the run
spider wait three men not just
spider-man but Peter Parker yeah like
it's identities out there he's got a
life's been flipped he's got a lot to
deal with already and then I feel like
it would just be way too compact and the
idea too of like okay let's say Mysterio
still alive how much more powerful would
it be if spider-man wins in this one
proves Mysterio is still alive and now
he really wants revenge and he teams up
with the sinister six in a later but
like it just lends a lot more weight to
it yeah and another word for it it would
be a lot more great super fighting it
would be you sound really intelligent
right now when you use that word thank
you yeah while you don't necessarily
need Mysterio to be like a three movie
villain that could actually work it's
like spider-man deals with the situation
then at the very end we we find yes some
retribution involving Mysterio and then
mysteriously a fool me twice spider-man
I wouldn't mind a version where Peter
feels like he can prove some way that
Mysterio still alive Jake Gyllenhaal's
Mysterio doesn't need to be in the movie
throughout it could just be a thing
where maybe by the end if that's a
that's like a big reveal or something to
help solve it because that's the only
way if your partner you solve the case
is proven you didn't kill him right
yeah maybe he is Jay jonah Jameson and
he's just an illusion a sidenote
this maybe you think that theory like
with sam raimi possibly directing dr.
strange multiverse of madness I don't
think they would have something work
Tobey Maguire shows up here but I was
like it would be pretty cool if like dr.
strange hops dimensions in multiverse of
madness and then Tobey Maguire responds
and walks right by bully Maguire and
full on retrospect here I think that the
retrospect on is good of a word not as
big as the other one it's a more
well-worn intelligence word true but
looking at the picture of what they're
talking about with having this sinister
six near I don't think the idea is bad I
just don't think now's the time maybe
that's all I'm saying like this plot
they presented I'm like that's pretty
cool I mean even if you did same thing
with daredevil in a later movie like did
all this in a later movie that's pretty
cool home run I think fantastic title I
just don't think it would be wise for
this third one then again this is all
rumors but it's fun to talk about as if
it's confirmed yeah cosmic wonder make
sure to subscribe to his channel we will
get that collab going gonna show up at
your place and you can swing over on a
roll of toilet paper a week sewing away
Merrill subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and hey
let's end this with a Jason Dolan Jay
dude so Jon apparently wrote you a rap
yeah hippity-hop saw here on the laptop
yeah and so um it's I've haven't read it
yet so I thought you'd find if instead
of John performing it I presented it to
you
alright that's gonna be great here we go
it's gonna be great I got a few words
here for Jason Dolan I'll keep this [ __ ]
snappy man no josh brolin always out to
help his buds he's a generous cat he
even saved our reject asses when our
camera crashed not only that our boy B
sling in mad words across the silver
screen y'all ever heard of Sydney Hall
yo where the F I can't say where John
that dude been well I'll tell you where
he came from
that's the mind of JD this man's a true
cinephile and a real cutie pinches
cheeks watch that smile form warm like
hot buttered popcorn but never salty nah
man not not JD so when the next vote
comes and I'm in the booth pullin you
can bet I'll pencil in my main man
Jason Dolan that's exactly how I
imagined that being read that's my
rapping style I just feel like there's
not enough energy in this poem I know I
know punch it up you know I was trying
to get the energy and all the brides to
rhyme but you know it's it's okay you
know I did my best for Jason Dolan
hopefully you got a better one next
month